je pense que les enfants restent
beaucoup trop assis à l'école je pense
qu'ils retiennent peut-être 10% de ce
qu'on leur apprend
[Musique]
pour moi le sport c'est quelque chose de
d'essentiel dans la société
d'aujourd'hui
ça permet d'avoir des cohésion de groupe
plein de choses comme ça qui font que la
société irait mieux si tout le monde
faisait du sport on est on est le pays
de la culture c'est vrai qu'on on adore
faire la bonne nourriture on adore tout
ce qui est l'art et je trouve que c'est
vrai qu'on devait on devrait regarder ce
qui se passe ailleurs parce que
franchement il ya des pays sur lesquels
faudrait pas prendre exemple sur
beaucoup de choses mais quand je vois
les états unis le les plans
universitaire comment le sport est mis
en avant
quand je vois en allemagne ou dans les
pays nordiques où tout l'après midi
c'est pas que du sport c'est juste des
activités on allait je parlais 2024 dans
six ans et je pense que ce serait le
moment d'en profiter pour un peu mettre
en avant le sport et les bienfaits du
sport je pense que les enfants restent
beaucoup trop ainsi à l'école je pense
qu'ils retiennent peut-être 10% de ce
qu'on leur apprend alors que si on leur
faisait faire du sport une étude qui
prouve que quand on se bouge plus notre
cas la capacité neuronale et plus accrue
dans la préhistoire les
les hommes quand ils ont commencé à
évoluer commence à chasser ils devaient
faire des jours de marché devait courir
sprinter aappma à côté de bêtes pour les
chasser et c est ça ils l'ont fait
pendant toute leur vie ça s'inscrit dans
nos génome petit à petit en tant qu on a
commencé à être sédentaires et à élever
les bêtes dans des enclos et on faisait
plus à ce besoin et c'est je pense le
sport est née de la passé juste à nous
il faut qu'on se dépense il faut qu'on
bouge nos articulations en fait débat
une valeur quand même éducative le sport
c'est dans la difficulté qu'on se
découvrir soi-même en tant qu'humain
tant que sportif en tant que pdg d'une
boîte que fonctionnaire de sport c'est
je pense le meilleur moyen d'aller au
bout de soi-même et même au delà et de
se découvrir vraiment découvrir ses
points faibles ses points forts est
justement de pouvoir réagir par rapport
à ça pour s'améliorer soi même dans tous
les points de la lie